also ich bin vielen usa unterwegs
gewesen ich habe nicht einmal da gelebt
in washington und new york was jetzt
glaube ich sehr klare wahlergebnis heute
abend sind für joe biden
aber klar ich war auch ich war auch im
ganzen land unterwegs also ich habe zwei
drei roadtrips gemacht und man trifft er
auch so ich habe halt menschen also ich
war mal auf einer politischen delegation
da und habe bewusst darum gebeten solche
vertreter der tea party zu treffen weil
ich einfach mit den reden wollte weil
ich verstehen wollte was die bewegt da
ich finde ja zur demokratie gehört auch
immer zu begreifen was die anderen
wollen und habe aber gemerkt man kommt
da nicht voran also keine akzeptanz für
homosexualität keine akzeptanz für ein
allgemeines gesundheitssystem keine
akzeptanz für europa so und es waren
freundliche menschen
wir haben vernünftig in dem ton
diskutiert aber wir haben dann noch mal
festgestellt okay wir sind
unterschiedlich und wir gehen jetzt mal
wieder getrennte wege
und das ist glaube ich verloren gegangen
also ich glaube dieses miteinander reden
das ist in den usa gerade nicht die
frage auf die ich so wissen hinaus
wollte inwieweit überhaupt ein gespür
haben schon für das was er wollte
entweder allein gehen wir nehmen das
land selektiv war also wenn man sich
deutsche medien anguckt dann versteht
man ja gar nicht warum da überhaupt noch
leute für jump sein können so das muss
gehört jetzt dazu also es gibt glaube
ich in deutschland eine sehr hohe ich
wenn man in deutschland abstimmen würde
ich weiß nicht wie hoch weil das
ergebnis neun einfach den 92
und das halten was ein bisschen ein
bisschen ein bisschen freundlicher
gesundes in europa sind die niederlande
interessanterweise mit ronan 32 33 das
haben wir jetzt auch gesagt deutschland
will ihn los wenn damit waren jetzt
nicht böse gemeint sondern auch zur
politik natürlich was sagen sie dazu
wenn wenn der präsident der usa sagt die
deutsche regierung gebaut und vom 11 ja
also ich feiere wenn er weg ist also das
muss ich sagen wenn ich möchte ich
möchte dass du da nicht mehr ist und
weißen haus ich halte den für rassisten
ich halte ihn für jemanden der selbst in
dieser corona pandemie spaltet und ich
möchte nicht dass solche leute die
weltpolitik bestimmen
so also ganz klar und ich glaube das
kann ich sogar für die ganze spd sagen
aber wenn du sagst du kannst für die
ganze spd sagen ich glaube du hast noch
hundertprozentig recht ja und du wirst
nie 100 prozent zustimmung in der spd
bekommt warum ist das eigentlich so ein
ungeschriebenes gesetz der politik dass
die meisten das dann aber
trotzdem nicht trauen zu sagen also euer
vizekanzler olaf scholz hat sehr klar
gesagt aber die meisten dann jedoch
daher wollen wir erstmal gucken
das weiß ich nicht also natürlich hält
man sich ein stück weit zurück und ich
habe das nicht möglich nicht weil ist
meint das fass ist übergelaufen also ich
meine überblick haus eines tages nicht
gemacht nur weil der außenminister hat
der außenminister kann das in seiner
position wenn das endlich kapiert habe
ehrlich gesagt ganz minister konnte das
halt auch der vizekanzler
also ich persönlich der pressesprecher
des außenminister sondern ich sitze
jetzt generalsekretärs
bundestagsabgeordneten als bürger dieses
landes und ich kann nur sagen
von meinen politischen werten und damit
bin ich erstmal vor allem bei der kultur
also wie geht man miteinander um und wir
respektiert man sich und wie tritt man
gegenüber frauen auf gegenüber
minderheiten geburt mensch mit
behinderung da hat dieser mensch nichts
mehr im weissen haus zu suchen und darf
keine verantwortung auf dieser welt
tragen so und dass mein wunsch ist dass
er heute verliert und ich bin noch ganz
optimistisch warum bist du optimistisch
weil ich also ich habe sehr viel in den
letzten wochen auch mit demokraten mit
wahlbeobachtern geredet ich lerne ja
auch so zu sagen was wir aus dem
amerikanischen wahlkampf für den
deutschen wahlkampf lernen können und
bin der vielen gesprächen und wenn man
sich die entwicklung 216 und jetzt
anguckt dann sind die kurven so das ist
für beiden immer besser wurde und für
trump immer schlechter in der korona
pandemie das war anders rum letztes mal
da hat clinton in den letzten wochen
verloren und trampert gewonnen und es
gibt gruppen zb ältere menschen die
wirklich enttäuscht sind vom auftreten
von trump in dieser kona pandemie weil
sie sagen der hat sich nicht um unsere
gesundheit gekümmert ist einfach und das
ist ganz kurz noch hören und das ist
etwas wo ich mich frage wen hat er
eigentlich dazu gewonnen und dass sie
das können nicht viele seien nicht mehr
verloren
du bist ein wirklicher kenner amerikas
du hast das gefühl dass beiden gewinnt
siehst du hast du dich den letzten
wochen damit beschäftigt was ist denn
wie man den usa za cars to victory
wie soll er auf diese 270 stimmen kommen
wir haben eben bei uns im newsroom
drüber gesprochen
georgia und texas wackeln das erste mal
das ist ungefähr so als würde dir bayern
gewinnen was war was ist wenn du das
glaubst beiden wird gewinnen wenn du
hoffst beiden wird gewinnen
wie soll er gewinnen also florida ist
entscheidend dann hast du
als ich die ganzen staaten auf sehen ich
weiß ich habe texas dazu gehört aber es
gibt andere swing states die irgendwie
ziemlich wackelig sind diese ganzen
staaten auch rund um den rest behält
also die ganzen industriestaaten das
sind ja leute die von hillary clinton
nicht angesprochen worden
das ist das was ich vorne auch somit mit
mit politischer kultur meint also
clinton hat es nicht geschafft diese
industriearbeiter die verzweifelt sind
weil sie jobs verlieren die anzusprechen
immer so getan als ob sie was besseres
ist biden hat die empathie angesprochen
aber er hat sie ich glaube er hat sie
nicht politisch glücklich gemacht und
vier jahren mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bate schaue ich
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren